(upbeat music)
- This episode of Otherwords was brought
to you by the letter R.
Wait, which R are we talking about?
The English alveolar approximant,
the Spanish trill,
the French uvular fricative?
Or maybe we're talking about the vowel R.
That's right.
There's a good argument that R
is at least sometimes, a vowel.
Does that mean that
your first grade teacher
was lying to you?
Not exactly.
R is an incredibly weird letter
with so many different
sounds and functions.
It's a wonder that we use one symbol
to represent them all.
And how people pronounce that one letter
can speak volumes about their history,
and social background.
You probably don't think much about R,
when you're talking,
but if there's one thing we
language nerds love to do
it's find the strange stories
beneath our ordinary
unconscious behaviors.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky,
and this is Otherwords.
(upbeat intro)
- Other words.
- As a child, you were probably
just told to memorize
that the vowels were A E I O U,
and sometimes Y.
But linguists define vowels
not so much as letters but sounds.
English has around 20 vowel phonemes
like ee, ih, eh, aa, ay,
ah, aw, oh, uh,
and ooh.
To qualify as a vowel,
a sound must meet a few general criteria.
First, it must be voiced,
meaning your voice box
vibrates when you make it.
Phonemes like ss, sh and h,
are voiceless, they're breath only.
Second, it should function as the nucleus
or peak of a syllable.
The central sound that gives a syllable
its length and volume.
It's the sound you'd sustain,
if you were singing the word.
♪ And I-i-i ♪
♪ Will always love you ♪
And third, it must be produced
with an unobstructed vocal tract.
What the heck does that mean?
Your vocal tract is basically
the entire mechanism that shapes sounds
from your vocal cord to your nasal cavity.
The different moving parts
are known as articulators,
and the main ones are the
tongue, upper lip, lower lip,
upper teeth, alveolar ridge, hard palate,
soft palate, uvula,
the pharyngeal wall, and the glottis.
Vowel sounds are made by
contorting these articulators
into different shapes,
like pursing the lips for u,
or flattening the tongue for a,
however if any of these
articulators touch each other,
like pressing the tongue
against the hard palate
for ll, or closing your lips for mm,
the vocal tract is obstructed,
and the resulting phoneme
is considered a consonant.
So what's going on in your mouth
when you make an R sound?
Well, that depends on where you're from.
Spanish speakers will either
tap the tip of the tongue
to the alveolar ridge as in pero,
or roll it as in perro,
known as a trill.
French speakers used to trill
their Rs with the tongue,
but it moved to the uvula
at the back of the throat, as in frere.
In English, the R sound is known
as the alveolar approximant,
which means the tongue
flicks backwards close
to the alveolar ridge,
but doesn't quite touch it.
It's a tricky move to pull off
and invisible from the outside,
which is why it's often the hardest sound
for young children to master.
What's weird is
that all these different sounds made
with different articulators
are represented
with just one symbol
and considered to be part
of the same phonetic family,
known as rhotics.
Interestingly, English is
one of very few languages,
along with Mandarin Chinese,
that uses the rhotic sound like a vowel,
In words like bird,
fur, learn, and mother,
the er sound is the
nucleus of the syllable.
♪ I'm like a bird ♪
- And unlike syllabic consonants,
like the N in button,
or the L in little,
there's no direct contact
between articulators,
leaving the vocal tract unobstructed.
This is why many linguists
believe that it meets
all the criteria of a phonetic vowel.
Up to now, I've only been
talking about the standard
American pronunciation of R,
but you're probably aware
that not all English
speakers say it the same way.
In fact, the pronunciation of R is one
of the most vivid differentiators
between English dialects.
For hundreds of years, the
people of England pronounced
their Rs hard,
similar to how it's done today in Ireland
and Scotland,
but starting in the mid 18th century,
it became fashionable
to drop the rhoticity
at the end of a word,
as in stah,
or before a consonant, as in paht.
At first, the trend was
considered lazy, and low class,
and many scholars railed against it.
Nevertheless, it spread
throughout much of England,
and then exported to
colonies in South Africa,
Australia, and New Zealand,
which all now speak what are known
as non-rhotic English dialects.
But because this trend
began after the colonization
of the new world,
most North American English speakers
kept their rhotic Rs, as I do today.
However, some Americans
who wanted to sound proper,
and upper class like the British
did start adopting the R dropping trend.
It was fashionable in the US
up until the early 20th century,
and you can hear it in
old films from the period.
- Don't miss a word.
- Today, there are still vestiges
of the dropped R in cities and regions
that had close contact with England,
like Boston, where you park your car
in Harvard yard,
and New York,
where you should never
forget to wear your slicker.
Some New Yorkers, even
up-glided the vowel R,
when it proceeded a continent,
as in it's my first time at the circus.
The southern aristocracy
also adopted R dropping,
as in I do declare,
which eventually spread
to most of the region,
including the African-American population
they had enslaved,
and is today a feature of
African-American English.
After the Civil War,
as the power centers of
America shifted westward,
the traditional rhotic R
became the standard once again,
and the dropped R, thanks
to its new association
with urban areas and immigrant
and Black communities,
reverted to a perception of
a low socioeconomic status,
and lack of education.
It's interesting that the
pronunciation of a single letter
depending on the time and
place, can have such a variety
of social connotations.
It's more evidence that
there is no one correct way
to shape a sound.
The letter R is a dramatic
symbol of how language works.
It's ever changing with a beautiful range
of variants, and yet,
as long as we can understand each other,
it just works.
Okay,
why is that?
The er sound is the nucleus of the symbol.
Syllable.
Ah, oh, o, eh, and oo.
(laughs)
Frere.